[音楽]
[拍手]
最初に皆さんにこんな質問を知ってきたらなと思っています
皆さん
ライターとストローの共通点って何かご存知でしょうか
カタカナ4文字であることをカタカナ3文字+棒線があることそれ以外
一つ共通点があります
5秒10秒くらい考えてみましょう
その間に多くの緊張が和らぐと思います
料亭を空中に出してみてください
マッチを使ってみましょう
そしてライターを使ってみましょう
その通りライターというのは片手がない障害者が作ったものです
そしてストローというのは首がすわらない障害者が作ったものです
私は就労困難な方の雇用創造
そんな理念のもと npo 法人 future dreamer 中免とて組織を
経営しています
僕らがやっていきたいことは
当たり前をつくっていくこと
ライターストローを見て皆さんが白いつや車椅子のように支援を受けていると思う
でしょうか
ライターやストローは欧米でもアジアでもみなさんの手元にある
どんな人だって働けるそして社会とつながれる
そんな当たり前を作っていきたいなと思ってこの組織を経営しています
今日皆さんに一つだけ伝えたいことがあって僕はまいりました
それは大丈夫っていうメッセージです
大丈夫というメッセージです
皆さんがうつ病で会社を辞めたとしまう
皆さんがシングルマザーになっている
皆さんが経理制の学校を卒業しても
障害
引きこもり生活保護ホームレス
難民難病薬物依存
hiv 犯罪歴がある若年性の認知症である lgbt である虐待を受けている
どんな人だって働けるそして社会とつながれる
そんな大丈夫という言葉をみなさんに伝えたくて今日はまいりました
ソースの僕の女の話をできたらいいなと思ってます
さあ歳の時にですね家族みんなで花火をしていました
塩付燃えカスとバケツの中に入れてごらんと母親に言われて
明るくきれいに映っていた花火は見えていたんですけど
花火夜景た瞬間僕は暗闇をわからなくなってしまいました
そしてバケツの中に萌果蔬いられなくなった
この子は暗い所が見えていない
そんなことに両親が気付き全国の病院を回り
網膜色素変性症という病名がつきました
そして私は普通の学校に行きました
小中校
さあ小学校の頃はですね1メートル離れるとサッカーボール1個分見える範囲があり
ました
中学高校でソフトボール大学で500円玉
今この光しか見えません少中古普通の学校に行ったんですね
普通の学校に入ってよかったなぁって周りの人に言われるんですいやいやちょっと待っ
てね僕はマンガとゲームと
活動ができませんでした
教室中にしか支援てないんです
教科書を大きくしてくれたりでもね僕には部活動ができなかったのでルール
仲間達成感一体感そんな言葉が全然わからなかった
そして漫画やゲームができないので人と話すがなんかネタがありませんでした
そして
小中校と学期に1回目の病院に変えます
目の見えない僕に対して先生方こう言うんです
展示覚えるといいよって
白い杖を付けるといいよ
パソコンを使えると便利だよって言うんです
いやいや待ってねっ
白いつえをついて出かける先がないから困っているのに
展示を覚えて誰とやり取りしたらいいか困ってるのにっ
パソコンを読んでどんな情報を得られたらこの心がすっきりするか分かるのにわから
ないから困ってるのにっ
富士山登る上で大事なことは靴でもウエアでも戦略でもないです
ご来光が綺麗なこと忘れなくと
支援の現場ではこの目的と手段がひっくり返ることがよくあります
僕は働けるのそして光って見え続けるのってそんなことを言って欲しかったです
そんな中18年間暗黒時代でした
今は人様の前でこうやって毎日のようながしますけどおそらく1日に今喋る量がですね
えっと10年前の3カ月分くらいかなと思います
あの杯ぐらいしか言えませんでした
そんな中3つのターニングポイントがありましたここにある
1回目のダイヤターニングポイント僕は2年間引きこもったんです
障害を持って目が見えなくて俺みたいな人ってどうやってきてるのかなと思って東京に
出てきました
そして福祉を勉強することにしました自分の存在を示すために自分の価値は勉強しか
ないと思っていたんだよ努力しているなりさーくん
勉強ができるないさーくん偏差値を取れないさーくん僕自身に価値がないからこの
形容詞や副詞に力を入れようっ
大学2年生の時にある必修科目が不可になっちゃったんです
人生が終わったと思ったんです人生があっ
目が見えなくて留年している目が見えなくて引きこもり
目が見えなくて不登校をれ捨てられんちゃうかなと思って
明日以降明日行こうと思ってたら学校に2年間いけなかったんです
ちょっと変わってるんです恋人にも家族にも友達にも誰にも言わなかったんです
丸2年間社会とつながりながらこんな一日です
九州からですねあが年に12回から暗くんですよ
学校いってくる奴って近くのマックに隠れてました
そしてあの恋人か急に泊まりに来たりすると今日授業じゃなかった来て早く終わったん
だよみたいな感じで
そして盆と暮れもちゃんと九州に帰ってたんですよ
今の時代就活って結構大変だよって全部嘘です
ぜーんぶぞ
そんな中大学4年生の社会福祉士の国家煙師国家試験もその日も僕は嘘ついてましただ
から弟からメールが来たんです
お兄ちゃん今日国家試験頑張ってね俺家にいるんだけどなと思うんだからそのメールを
受け取りました
手元には合格祈願のお守りがいっぱいありましたもらったものが合格祈願より俺は祈り
たいことがあるぜって思ってました
ん
そして11反省文のようにですねメールを返さ
裏切ってごめんなさいって言えばいい
そして国家試験が終わった時間の頃メールを送りました皆無事に終わったよってメール
かと思ったんですけど
ごめんなさい学校2年言ってませんでした
誰も責めなかったですそして父やこう言ってくれた
俊輔もスーパーマンじゃなかったんだなっ
うねっ失敗したことなかったんですよ大学2年生まで
失敗したら捨てられると思ったので
その時は神に愛されているなぁと思いました
1個目の引きこもったことによって僕は自分で人生で選んで初めて失敗するという経験
ができました
そして2つ目に
皆さんよく僕をやって話をするんで何の仕事されてるんだけどだいたい営業の仕事です
かって言われますからこの際会社を経営していますって
こんなことがありました
当事者として悶々として東京に出てき
そして福祉を勉強したもっと悶々としたんですよ
だってしょう従来の健常者の先生が障害者ってなって授業するんですよねちょっと俺
20年だぜって思ったりとか
クラスメイト qr 女子でゲームしながら授業を受けてるんです僕今まで慣れと経験
と勘とキャラで生きてきたんですよ
なぜとき
英検の観とキャラでごまかしながらきたんですよ
そしたら福祉が障害者の大変さをいっぱい僕に見せつけてきたんで
矢部入れないこの業界にとっ
そんな中僕は経営という仕事に出会いました私前後のか
大変でしたよ入社倍率4000倍ぐらいの会社にました
30名のコンサルタントで一番社くらいの感謝の ipo やまんどエア
役員の紹介業手伝いする会社に僕は大学に行きながら
まあ優勝のインターシップに行くことになりました
いっぱいいいことがあったんです始発から終電まで仕事して毎晩のように会食があって
夜中に資料史料が作れなかった親にお願いしたりとかしました
そんな中まず一つ目人生で初めて
結果を求められたんですよ結果を
今まで結果を求められたことがなかったんです1位から最下位まで営業成績が出る会社
でしたして不謹慎ながらもう僕が数十外すと上司が誤ってください
でそれ見てていやね佐賀数字始めた花を外したら私のせいですと誤ってみて幸せだった
んですよ
はされているっていう
ずっと自分ひとりで来たのが結果求められた
それは自分の辞書に相手というのが生まれたんですよ
お客様とか部下とかチームっていうのが超幸せだなぁと思ってそんな中飛び込み営業し
ハタチ前後の僕に系のアドバイスなんか何もできなかったんです
でも皆さん最後にこう言ってくれたんです代作ん
また会いに来てくれよッ
なぜかというと経営者の孤独と就労困難な僕の子どっか一緒だったんです
答えのない苦しむに向き合っている人に必要とされたり褒められる機会はほとんどない
だから僕はその頃これだけ目を近づけたらまだ資料が見えてました
杖をつきながら何か出来ることないですかって
その思考サッコしてる感がなんか近かったんでしょうね
そこから僕は経営者の孤独に向き合う仕事をしようと決めたんです
恋人でも友達でも家族でも先生でも医療者でもなく僕を最初に必要としてくだな経営者
だったんです
だから僕は2つ目の経営という仕事に出会ってですね
初めて自分の辞書に相手というのもが生まれて
自分の人生が変わりました
今度3つ目
僕今この光しか見えないんですよ
10年前に失明をしました
失明したんですけどそんな大変なことないんです今職員が約20名
就労困難なトレーに受けてメンバー約80目100名の組織を束ねてます
そんなに難しくないです
失明をして1個だけ困ったことがあるんです皆さんなんだと思います
失明をしてい
それは
鏡の前で自分の存在がわからなくなったことです
失明するまで偏差値はウラ毛っていうのに一生懸命すがっていました
説明をしてですね僕は一つの曲が増えたんです
ておか曲がぁ
それは銃を探しているんです
自分の存在って何だろうって誰か教えてくれよって
もう偏差値や売上そしていろんな武器を持とうと思ったんですけどそれじゃあ僕の心の
ドキドキが止まらなかったんです
自分のどこ行ったって俺どこ行ったって思うようになりました
自分の存在って何だろう
皆さんもそうじゃないですかおかあちゃんもサラリーマンも学生も傾斜もん
自分の存在って何だろうって皆さん思いますよね
僕は先ほど話したようにちょっと変わっているんです
父が国外図1の異名でお姉ちゃんがが&心で僕は難病で僕は帰国子女で僕は二通行に
無理やりって大学7年かやって家に年間引きこもって
大学在学中から系の仕事して3年前には髄膜炎で病気で死にかけていろんな社会方が僕
に降ってくるんです
でも観ていただいてわかる僕に幸せなんです
今100名の組織を束ねてます97%就労困難者なんです
17歳から68歳まで40以上の病気を持ったメンバーが僕の部下にいますそれでも
幸せなんです
毎日台が自殺未遂します毎日誰か入院をします
そしてたまに訴えるぞと言われます
それでもねー幸せなんです
だが皆さんに言われるです歯医者さんとその笑顔の限定は何ですか
なんか行っちゃってるんじゃないですかみたいないやそうではないですよ
その映画の件とはなんですかって言われたら僕はいつもこう答えます
今あなたが笑顔って言ってくれたことですよ
自分の存在って何だろうってモヤモヤしながらずっと自分のことって自分で染め最中に
なって思ったんです
ちがかったんです
相手がいるから自分がいるんです
そういうことに失明をとして気づけたんですだからも手の傷ないんです皆さんがこう
やって拍手したり笑ってくださって
あ俺もわからないけど皆さんに示してもらってこの時だけが止まったんです
だから今僕がやっている仕事っていうのは誰かの相手になるって仕事なんです
3000万人の就労困難者そして400万円の傾斜
大丈夫だぜっていうのが仕事ここの隣に立ちはいつもとはいえどうせだってっていう人
たちです
それたちに大丈夫だからって俺が怒らさっていうのが僕の仕事です
ています
3つのターニングポイント引きこもって初めて人生で失敗することができて人を頼ら
れるようになった
ケイト仕事に出会って自分の一緒に相手というものが生まれた
そして失明をして誰かの相手になる
相手が自分を示してくるそんなことに気づくことができました
その中今僕は何やってるか3つの仕事をしています
仕事の5割は障害者雇用とか多様な働き方改革という猟奇のコンサートイングしてい
ます
全国でそして1行会社しかクライアントを持たないです
そして必ず傾斜に出てきてもらいますなのでリサイクル屋さんから参拝の
会社から清掃の会社から飲食店から木くずやさんカラオケ屋さんから印刷の会社から
40以上の業界業種を見ています
何でかって言うとみんなに選ばしてやりたいんですよ
いろんな仕事男性
でいろんな業界でこの支援をすることによって宮崎でも北海道でも広島でもみんなを
幸せにすることができる私の一つの仕事は障害者雇用のコンサー担としています
おそらく日本でトップのコンサートだと領域や定着率の誰から見てもそうだと思います
2つ目2年間相談お薬
2000件ぐらいを受けます2000件くらい当社家族の人の視線が怖くて髪の毛ここ
まである人とか
身長がこれぐらいしかない人とか犯罪歴が7がある人とか
lgbt の人いろんな人たちに毎日のよねますそして良いですからない大丈夫だぜっ
て
そして三つ目に光栄検証してますねに200ぐらい
スピーチ挨拶公園検証する機会がありますなぜなら
この取り組みを今日知れば無理信じする家族が減ると思っています
この取り組みは今日知れば障害を持つ子どもころそうかーちゃんが減ると思います
この取り組みを知ればうつ病で自殺する人が減るかなと思ってますんで
200のうち100ぐらいが無料やボランティアです
なんで私自身は大丈夫って皆さんに言うために起業
o さんのコンサートイングし当社にダイレクトにですっ出会い
して講演研修をしています
そんなことをしていたらいろんな結果が出てきました
写真もすると思いますけれども
20年間引きこもってた人が3年取りに向けて it の会社で正社員で働いています
写真に写ってるのは50代で障害が5種類もある人が正社員でボーナスをもらえながら
働いています
でも心配なんで2ヵ月に1回ぐらいそろそろリストラで使って迷路くるんですけど
いやーされめしっボーナスが少ないって言ったらもらっただけやん楽し
5年間引きこもってる人が僕と迷路さん福士たわけで家から出てきたりします
そんなことができています
誰だって働ける
働くというのはフルタイム働けて空気が読めて愛想笑いができて excel ができ
てプレゼンができるじゃないです
そうだった僕プレゼンしかできないんででも一応幸せに世界中で仕事をさせていただい
てます働くって
強みが1個あればいい嫁を受け止められる素直さが1個あればいい
僕は世界一開かれ視覚障害者でキャッチコピーを持っています
それはなぜか10年前のある日トイレポットこの言葉思いついたんですよ
不安だったんでしょう40から60くらいで光を失うというこの病気がー
だから僕はこのキャッチコピーをつけました明るくいきたいなっ
で暗いときこの明るいモードに入っていけるんだよ
で僕は
まだ未練があるみたいです
明るく生きておいたほうが長くヒカリってみるんちゃうかなって思ってるでしょ
でももう進行が進んできました
おそらくあと数年で僕は光を失うでしょう
それでも世界一開かれ視覚障害者
そんな生き方ができる準備できたんじゃないかって場合の人に言われてるような気がし
ます
今日いらっしゃってる皆さんに届けたい
どんな人だって働ける社会とつながれる
大丈夫だぜってそんな言葉をくれたなかった
そして皆さんも既に誰かにとっての相手になっている
そんなことに気づいていただけたらなというふうに思っています
ありがとうございました